هو صحيح حتى عندنا مثلا في الحاله اليمنيه
الان يعني من نفس المنطقه ومن نفس العوائل
يتقاتلوا فيما بينهم واللي مع الشرعيه
واللي مع الحوثيه لكن نحن نقاتل باسم
الدوله ايضا منظومه القاعده وهي الان
الكبرى
يعني هذا الامر ولا في حاله كمون
وخلايا نائمه باستثناء العناصر والخلايا
المرتبطه بالحوثيه يعني فاعلين نتيجه
التخادم الموجود بين الحوثيه والقاعده لكن
ايضا في الحرب يعني
الاوكرانيين الروسيه خرج مفتي
مسلمي اوكرانيا ولبس العسكريه ايضا وافتى
انه قتال الروس من اوجب الواجبات وهذا
جهاد في سبيل الله ونفس الكلام مفتين
اخرين للمسلمين في الجانب الروسي افتوا
بنفس الفتوى
فاسرع معقد هناك محاوله لتوظيف الاسلام
واستقطاب
مقاتلي ومسلمي الدولتين لصالح
دولهم لكن مساله استقطاب مقاتلين جهاديين
ارهابيين
ورغم في موجود في اوروبا كثير لم يتم
استقطاب الجزء الكثير منهم
وهناك ناس مستعدين ايضا للذهاب الى
اوكرانيا
هناك حذر من استخدامهم بشكل مكثف لكن انا
اتفق معاه لو طالت الحرب
ممكن يتم توظيفها وهذا يقتضي ان وجود
الداعم وجود مساحات الان وجود الداعم وجود
الدعم وجود التعبئه وتبنيه من قبل الدول
هذا المساله مش موجوده المساله الاهم انه
البيئه الحاضنه لمثل هذه الحركات داخل
اوكرانيا يعني وحتى عند الروس انا اعتقد
انها ضعيفه هي بيئه مختلفه يعني على مستوى
القوميه واللغه والدين وايضا جزء منهم
يعني رؤوا انها حرب بين الاطراف غير مسلمه
والمساله الاهم انه هناك تجربه حتى نقول
لدى الاسلام المعتدل خليك من القاعده
وداعش
بمساله ان يكون ان يتحولوا الى اعداء من
ادوات اداره الحروب البارده بين الغرب
والشرق وعندهم تجربه سابقه وخسروا وايضا
الغربيين ايضا مساله وايضا حتى العرب
والمسلمين مساله توظيف الجهاد في اداره
الصراعات بين الدول يتحول الى كارثه لاحقه
عليهم وعلى دولهم فالجميع حذر لكن
الاشكاليه اللي بيواجهها الغرب الان انه
كثير من المقاتلين اللي بيندفعوهم من
اليمين المتطرف وهذا يعني سيواجه الغرب في
الفتره القادمه مشكله من هؤلاء اللي
يندفعوا للقتال تحت يعني الجيش الاوكراني
وايضا حتى
الروس ايضا خايف من مساله توظيف الخطاب
الديني بين المسلمين ان يرتد عليهم فهناك
حذر في هذه المساله من الاطراف المتقاتله
كادوى روسيا واوكرانيا